[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to what's new
in Android but first we'll start with
this distribution you saw in the keynote
to introduce the dynamic ad bundles
tours demo was pretty clear it's pretty
easy for you all you have to do is click
a different menu when you build your
application and we're gonna save you
some space it's gonna be faster and
easier to download for your users to
download your app let's talk about
Android jetpack this is a set of
components as well as guidance on how to
build better Android applications all of
you are familiar with most of what is in
Android jetpack already what we're doing
is adding to it over time with stuff
that's going to make it even better
and we're also improving it over time
one of the major steps that we're taking
is what I like to think of as a refactor
because it's her refactor and we're
doing a whole lot of tedious renaming
and we're also providing tools to make
it easier for you to do the similar
refactoring you're going to need to do
in your application as well as in the
Android studio everything is being
renamed to something more appropriate
called Android X jetpack architecture is
about the architecture components that
were announced last year at i/o and then
iterated with feedback from the
community and finally went one dot o in
the fall work manager is currently in
preview there's going to be a talk about
it
also navigation it turns out that up vs
back is a hard problem for applications
to solve we are making that much easier
and we're integrating with the tool to
make it even easier yet cut lean it's
this little thing we announced last year
so we are busy we want to make it better
for all the Kirkland developers out
there I'm sure there's a lot of you here
today so some of the things we've been
doing the art team has been really busy
with d8 r8 and art itself they've been
looking at the bytecode generated by the
cutting compiler divinized some of the
bytecode patterns that were different
from the ones generated by the java
programming language compiler and they
developed the optimizing for those
patterns we've also been adding a lot of
nobility annotations to our java api is
both in the core libraries so lib core
and our support libraries to make it
easier for you to use the platform api
so when you're when you're in catalan
and finally we launched on github a new
library called android KTX it's a set of
cutting extensions for existing platform
API and the goal here is to try to take
advantage of some of the cutting
language features to make existing API
is easier to use they're already easier
to use just by using cotton but with the
extension that gets even better
so it slices is our new approach to
remote content that you can actually use
to project UI
into your own app or into other apps
that support it it's very structured
this is not sort of here as a canvas or
an absolute layout go nuts with it we
give you a structure to fill out and a
whole bunch of very flexible templates
in which to populate that data with some
display hints so that the receiving end
of the slice a slice host kind of knows
what to do with it these are interactive
these are updatable this is meant to be
something that holds rich UI sliders
controls live information possibly
videos things that actually feel like
real UI as opposed to a snapshot of
something happening in a distant process
somewhere slices are addressable by
content URI and this is how they're
passed around the system and how they're
passed along to app indexing to be shown
in contexts like search and then finally
slices is entirely inside the support
library it's entirely in jet pack so
it's backwards compatible you can use
slices all the way back to API 19
related to slices is actions you can
think of these as shortcuts with
parameters ramallah likes to think of
them as visible intents this is
essentially a deep link into your app
with some additional payload it's not
just a link to music it's linked to a
particular album or something like that
and you saw these as well in the keynote
showing up in a predictive space inside
our app launching experienced actions
you define in an actions XML file that
goes into your apk or app bundle and
that's who can get registered with that
indexing so that search results and
predictive features can show those
actions
[Music]